SPEAKER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Well, today
I'm going to give
the fourth and final
case study of the course.
And everything I'm
going to talk about
is my thesis research
in one form or another.
So this is work that's
definitely in progress.
And in a lot of cases,
we haven't really
drawn conclusions yet.
So it'll be quite
rough and ready.
But I hope it'll be informative
and raise some questions
for you.
The focus of my
thesis research is--
well, broadly speaking,
finding approaches
to manufacturing microfluidic
devices using polymers.
And for many of you,
I think microfluidics
will be something you know
at least a little about.
Essentially, microchips that
manipulate very small volumes
of fluids to perform various
experimental, or diagnostic, or
other engineering tasks.
And we were interested
in developing processes
and choosing materials that will
help us make these things very
cheaply so that they can be
used at the point of care
in the case of diagnostic
devices, and so forth.
Now, one particular
process that's
of great interest for
this is the imprinting
of thermoplastic
polymeric layers.
Hot embossing is what
we're going to call it.
And for a start, let
me say why polymers
are interesting for making
these sorts of devices.
I think I see
three main reasons.
Firstly, they're cheap compared
to silicone or glass, which
are other materials
that you might think
of as being obvious
candidates to fabricate
these microscopic fluidic
channels, and valves,
and pumps, and so forth.
So polymers are cheap.
Second thing is, they're
often transparent.
And that's really important.
When you have a biological
sample inside this device
and you're trying to
look at how it behaves
in response to certain
stimuli, either you're
exposing it to a dye
that will make cells
with certain
properties fluoresce.
You need to see
that fluorescence.
Or you're prodding
a cell somehow
to see whether its
stiffness gives you
information about
its disease state,
something along these lines.
Anyway, but transparency
is an important property.
And thirdly, a lot of plastics
are mechanically tough,
which makes them highly
suitable to use in the field
at the point of care,
in doctors' surgeries
and so forth.
So these are the three reasons
why polymers are interesting.
And imprinting them is
interesting as a process,
because that itself
has the potential
to be quick and cheap.
You can imagine a
cycle imprinting
a thermoplastic polymer
occurring in around a minute.
And you can choose what kind
of size workpiece you machine.
You could machine
anything from the size
of a single microfluidic
chip, all the way up
to continuous reels
of polymeric film.
And indeed, the reel to
reel printing approach
is something that's been
used in industry already
for quite rudimentary devices.
3M has a patent on
hot embossing reels
of thermoplastic polymers.
And so it's a pretty
flexible process.
And microfluidics
aren't the only sorts
of things you might
think of making with it.
A lot of optical devices
could be made this way.
You could think of imprinting
refractive elements.
Or actually 3M's
patent is so that they
can imprint the reflective
films that are laminated
onto the front of road signs.
Imprinted into those films are
many parallel, V-shaped grooves
that act as corner
[? key ?] reflectors
so that the street signs reflect
light incident from any angle.
And so those sorts of
optical applications
are also pretty crucial.
But anyway, let me just
describe how the process works.
What I'm illustrating
here is not
a role to role printing
process, but something
where the workpiece is
about the size of a wafer.
So tens of millimeters
in diameter.
And first thing we
need is a hard stamp,
a tool that's been
microfabricated
using some other process.
This tool might have
been etched from silicon.
It might have been
electroplated with nickel.
It might itself be a polymer,
but one that doesn't soften
at the processing temperatures.
Elastomers like PDMS,
polydimethylsiloxane
are actually quite attractive
as stamp materials.
So we have this stamp.
We have two heated
plates to heat
the stamp and the
workpiece, and a means
of applying a load normal to
the surface of the workpiece.
Usually what happens
is the material
is heated above what's
called its glass transition
temperature.
And for anyone who isn't
familiar with this,
thermoplastics essentially
are composed of an entangled
network of polymer molecules.
And there are one
or more temperatures
for a given polymer at which
those entanglements loosen.
And the chains can
slide past one another.
And the stiffness and
the effective viscosity
of the material around
that temperature
falls by several
orders of magnitude.
So above that temperature, it's
highly flexible, easily formed.
Below that temperature, it's
much stiffer and useable
as a device.
So we go above the glass
transition temperature
to soften it.
How far we go above is an
important question to answer.
That's a crucial
parameter to choose.
We then apply a load.
That load is going to be
ramped up over some time
that we have a choice about.
That might be an
important parameter.
We hold that load for some time
to allow the material to flow,
to fill cavities in the stamp.
And while the load
is still applied,
we cool down usually,
cool the material
to below its glass transition
temperature, and finally,
remove the load.
And often, that removal step has
a lot of technical challenges
involved in it,
because of differential
thermal contraction of
the workpiece in the tool.
So that gives you
some idea that there
are at least four parameters
that we need to decide upon,
temperature, a load,
and two times associated
with that load.
There are probably
more parameters
that we're interested in.
Now, at this point,
I should also
mention a rather
similar process that has
quite different applications.
And that is thermal nano
imprint lithography.
This is, essentially,
hot embossing,
but done on very thin layers of
polymer, thinner than a micron.
And these layers have been spun
onto a much harder surface,
usually a silicon wafer.
And the beauty of
this process is
that it allows sub
micron features
to be transferred to the wafer.
This is, I think, a
really exciting process.
It has the potential to
revolutionize lithography
and semiconductor manufacturing,
because the resolution
with which features
can be transferred
is not limited by the
wavelength of light.
Usually you would pattern
a photo resist layer
with some kind of projection,
optical projection system.
And we've really got
to the stage where
critical dimensions
of transistors
are making that a big challenge,
making the optical lithography
systems cost tens or hundreds
of millions of dollars.
So in this case, we have
this spun on polymer layer.
It's dissolved in an organic
solvent, spun on the solvent.
It evaporates.
And then the spun on
layer is a thermoplastic.
It can be softened.
You press the the
nano fabricated stamp
into the wafer.
And ideally, squeeze
all the material
from below the individual
features of the stamp.
Now, in reality,
that's not possible.
And there is a small
residual polymer
layer that's left there.
So you can imagine, once we've
removed the stamp or the mold,
we have some extremely
thin regions of polymer.
And then imagine that we want to
pattern, to etch away material
in the wafer underneath.
The plasma or the
etching solution
to which the wafer is
exposed will quite readily
break through that
residual polymer layer
and remove the material.
So these processes are similar.
In many ways, they actually
often use the same polymers.
But the boundary conditions, the
mechanics are rather different.
And so I'll talk a little
bit about nano imprint,
but mostly the
results that I'm going
to show you are to do with
micro hot embossing, where
the workpiece is substantially
thicker than the diameters
or the depths of the features
that are being patterned.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
about creating the mold,
during the mold removal process,
do you have the mold walls
getting [? dilated? ?] Because
the pattern is getting taken
off and it might have a
[? dimension ?] [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Yes, that was
an excellent question.
You've hit on one of the
most important challenges
of [INAUDIBLE] embossing.
And [INAUDIBLE] was
asking, are there problems
with dimensional stability
of the walls, the side
walls during de-molding?
And I'll show you some
results that relate to that.
So yes, good point.
Anyhow, as I already
mentioned, there
are several parameters
to do with the process
that we need to pick,
temperatures, load times,
loading durations.
The range that those
parameters can take
will be limited by the
capabilities of the machine we
have, the physical
properties of the polymer
we're trying to pattern,
what temperature does
it start to burn, and so forth.
What about the
material underneath?
If we're doing nano
imprint lithography,
are there temperature
constraints
that the wafer underneath
has to observe?
So that's what
constrains the process.
And, of course, we might also
be making engineering decisions
about what type of
polymer we're going to use
to achieve a certain end.
And indeed, we might have some
flexibility in the pattern
that we are going to emboss.
We might think about designing
a pattern with an eye
to manufacturability, something
that will be easier to imprint
with less variability.
And that is one of the questions
that I'm trying to answer.
Mohammed.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] how
do you [INAUDIBLE] the stamp
[? control? ?]
PROFESSOR: Right,
well, the stamp
can be made in a variety
of ways that are usually
traditional microfabrication.
So one particularly
easy way of doing
it would be to use a process
called deep reactive ion
etching.
And here I'm talking
about micro embossing,
where the features are several
microns to many microns.
And essentially, this is just
etching very deep trenches
into a silicon wafer
using a plasma process.
I could go into great
detail about how that works,
but essentially, it's a
fluorine based chemistry.
The precursor gas is SF6.
And you build up these
very deep, narrow trenches
in the silicon wafer
by a series of steps.
So in fact, you would
start with the silicon
with a photoresist
mask or something.
You'd do a brief fluorine based
plasma etch that would remove
small amounts of material.
That's roughly isotropic.
So if you want
vertical sidewalls,
you've got to do something else.
And the something
else is depositing
a polymeric passivation layer.
So you change the
gas in the chamber
to C4F8, which creates
what's essentially
a teflon coating that passivates
the sidewall of the trench
that's developing.
Then you go back to the
SF6, build up a new notch,
and do this many times,
alternate many times.
So whatever way you
pattern the stamp.
Silicon actually, as we will see
later, for de-molding reasons,
is actually a lousy material
to use for the stamp.
So then you might go one step
further, electroplate nickel
into that etched wafer,
peel off the nickel,
and use that as the stamp.
Much tougher.
Or you might use
more novel materials,
things like metallic
glasses, which
are alloys with an
amorphous structure that are
both very hard and very tough.
They would be great
materials for a stamp.
AUDIENCE: So what
you mentioned--
you said that you're not
limited to wavelengths
of the light in this process.
But however to make the stamp,
then you are limited to--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, yes.
limitation exists.
PROFESSOR: So what I
just described here
was for micro embossing.
I'm sort of describing
two processes
in parallel that have
great similarities,
but not in terms of scale.
So this would be for features
that are a micron or larger.
If you want to make
sub micron features,
then you're quite right.
You need a process that will
let you make a stamp with sub
micron features, and
electron beam lithography
is a great candidate for that
where you actually would--
you would start
with a silicon wafer
with a 100 nanometer
thick layer of a radiation
sensitive resist.
Then you would just actually
steer a focused electron beam
across the surface, scan
it across the surface
in the pattern that you wanted.
And that will give you 5
nanometer resolution or better.
The trouble is, it takes ages
because it's a serial process.
You're scanning the
electrons over the surface.
So once you've made the stamp,
you've paid however many $1,000
for the stamp.
You can stamp it in in a
minute into as many substrates
as you like.
And that's really the
reason for nano imprint.
OK, so keep both of
those processes in mind.
But a lot of the assertions
I'm going to make from now on
are all about the
micron scale embossing.
So as I said, there are
lots of different parameters
we can choose to do
with the process,
to do with the material
we're embossing,
to do with the pattern
that we're embossing.
And the overall
mission that I suppose
we have is to try to provide
tools for people who are using
this process to
achieve the desired
microstructure with as little
time, energy, cost as possible.
So if you're processing
a certain material,
can you pick a pattern that will
take 30 seconds to replicate
instead of a minute at
the available processing
conditions?
So that presupposes,
of course, that we
have some specification on what
satisfactory replication is.
The most obvious
specification would
be that every
cavity in the stamp
has been filled with polymer,
even the narrowest ones.
That would be a good
specification to use.
Another good
specification that's
really important for
nano imprint lithography
is to make the thickness of
those residual polymer layers
very uniform.
And that's important
because it does
take some time for
the etching process
to break through
that residual layer.
And if the residual layer
varies in thickness,
the time taken to break
through it will be different.
And then you'll get different
properties of the underlying
structure.
So let's say you've imprinted
this 100 nanometer thick
polymer layer.
And on this side, the
residual layer is really thin.
And on this side
it's twice as thick.
You then expose this
with a fluorine plasma.
You're trying to etch the
silicon underneath here.
You're going to end up
with a deeper trench
here than you are here
because of the time
it took to get through that.
So coming up with ways
of designing the stamp so
that the residual layer ends
up being as uniform as possible
is a really pressing challenge
actually for this lithography
technique to be adopted.
Anyhow, so what we're all about
is simplified modeling tools
that can be used as
part of the design loop
that are computationally
efficient enough
to give results in a
reasonable amount of time,
and that represent reality well.
So that implies that we need
some way of characterizing
the tool that we're using,
the materials that we're
using efficiently so that
we can get information
about the physical
properties of these things
with a minimum of fuss.
Now, I'm just going to
split the problem up
into three notional
length scales
so that we can have a clearer
picture of what's going on.
And at the largest
length scale you
can think of variations
in the quality
of the embossed
features from one side
of the substrate to the other.
And that might occur because
the two heated plates that
are compressing the
stamp and the substrate
are not perfectly parallel.
So the pressure's
greater on one side.
It might be because one of
the plates is bowed or wavy.
Or it might be to do
simply with the mechanics
of the substrate itself.
If that substrate is behaving
as a viscous fluid, say,
then as you compress that
substrate, that flat, polymer
substrate, you're
going to expect
to see, in fact, a parabolic
distribution of pressure
across it.
So there are various
things to consider there.
And then at what I'm going
to call the device scale,
there are these
pattern dependencies
where the arrangement
of features on the stamp
can have a profound effect on
how well defined the features
end up being.
And what I've sketched here,
which is really just a sketch,
it suggests if
there are features
that are slightly more
closely packed together,
then they may fill earlier,
or maybe sometimes later
than regions that are
less densely packed.
And if that's the
case, then maybe you
want to put some
design rules in place
that will constrain the
variation of density
of features on the stamp.
Finally, we've got at the
smallest scale effects
to do with individual features.
So if an individual
gap is too small, say,
that's going to be very hard
to force polymer into it.
And that could be a showstopper.
So we've got these three
different length scales.
I've alluded to these
sorts of problems,
bowing of the patterns, non
parallelism of the patterns.
They relate to the
substrate scale effects.
This shows one particular
substrate that we embossed.
This is a square of
PMMA, which is acrylic,
which is about 100
millimeters square.
We embossed with a wafer that
had been uniformly patterned
with some silicon posts,
roughly 100 microns in diameter.
And we just use this
as a probe to look
at our embossing machine and
see how uniform a pattern could
be produced.
Now, aside from the fact that
huge chunks of the silicon
wafer broke off
during de-molding--
and that's a good illustration
of some of the problems that we
face--
we were able to look at the
topography of the pattern
at different locations
on the wafer.
We did that using
an interferometer,
scanning from above,
measuring the topography.
And so we were able
to see various things,
that the emboss depth was higher
on this side than on this side.
Then near the edge of the
wafer the embossed features
tailed off in height.
And so these are
the sorts of things
that we need to come up
with ways of predicting
so that we can counteract them.
Anyway, what I'm going
to concentrate on
for the rest of this
talk, in fact, is pattern
dependent non uniformity,
which is, in many ways,
the most challenging
to deal with.
Effects to do with
the edge of the wafer
become important when you're
trying to eke out one or two
extra devices.
You're trying to save a
little bit of material.
But if the actual
design of the device--
there may be many
devices across a wafer.
If the design of the
individual device is faulty
and it will never
replicate properly,
then you're in real trouble.
So trying to get
an understanding
of what patterns will form
well and what patterns will not
is crucial.
And so although we are
working towards a unified way
of dealing with
this, I'm just going
to talk mostly about the
pattern dependencies now.
So I've mentioned all of
these different questions that
need to be answered, factors
that need to be chosen when
you're designing a new process.
And some of them are going
to be continuous variables,
and some of them will
be discrete choices.
And it's not absolutely
clear which will be which.
I've really split
the decisions up
into three categories,
the decisions
you have to make
about the pattern
you're going to emboss, what
are the shapes of the features?
Rectangles, circles,
triangles, how big they are,
and how they are
oriented on the stamp?
And that can be
important when you're
starting to think about
radial thermal contraction
of the parts, or about
anisotropic material
properties.
So there you've got-- you know,
size is a continuous variable,
and the feature
shape you might think
of as being a discrete choice.
When it comes to the
substrate itself,
then you've got to
decide on the material.
Various materials soften
at different temperatures.
Some of them exhibit a range
of temperatures over which they
behave rather like a rubber.
Others don't really have
much of a rubbery region.
They just flow
very easily as soon
as you're above the glass
transition temperature.
So that's a decision
that has to be made.
And in micro
embossing, often you're
picking between a variety of
off the shelf substrates, PMMA,
plexiglass, polycarbonate,
materials like this,
where these are technical
grade materials.
They're molecular weight.
In other words, the average
length of the polymer chains
is not necessarily well
documented or well defined.
So in that sense,
your material choice
might be a discrete decision.
On the other hand, if
you're spinning the polymer
onto the wafer, and
you're dissolving it,
then you do have the option of
choosing the molecular weight,
and therefore, defining the
viscosity as essentially
a continuous variable.
So those are things that might
need to be thought about.
And, of course,
there's the thickness.
Either how thickly do
you spin this resistor?
And that, a lot of
research in the field
demonstrates the
optimal thickness
is a strong function
of what pattern you're
trying to emboss, how many
voids there are in the stamp.
So the thickness of
that might be important,
and also the thickness
in micro embossing
where the substrate is
a millimeter thick, say.
That's also a decision
that has to be made.
So and the third
category, of course,
is the process parameters,
the temperature, pressure,
hold time, and so forth.
Now, there's an awful
lot of variables there.
And if one were to just take
a purely empirical approach
and try doing a full factorial
or a fractional factorial
exploration of the
space, it would
start to look pretty
much like a nightmare.
And luckily, we don't have to
stumble around in the dark,
because we do already
have some reasonably
good physical intuition about
how these materials behave.
And, of course, there's
a huge research field
to do with characterizing
these bulk materials,
building theoretical
models of how they behave,
fitting data to those models.
And I'm sure mechanical
engineers here
will be familiar with this sort
of way of describing polymers
in a simplified manner,
where you build up a model.
In this case, this is
a one dimensional model
that sums up the viscoelastic
behavior of the polymer using
a combination of springs,
elastic, nondissipative
elements.
And these elements here are
dashpots, which are essentially
viscous components and damp.
Yes, exactly, they
dissipate energy.
So the various stiffnesses
and dissipation factors
for the springs and dashpots
may be non-linear functions
of temperature.
They may be non-linear
functions of strain rate,
and, in fact, almost always are.
And so there are
many theses that
have been written trying to
characterize these materials.
And building on those
experimental approaches
are simulation models.
There are finite element
models of these polymers that
have been lovingly built up.
And so with enough
information about the polymer
with a detailed model of the
stamp that you were thinking
of embossing, and
knowing something
about the dimensional tolerances
of the machine you have,
you could do a simulation
and perhaps predict
what was going to happen.
The trouble is, it would
probably take years.
Because when you start
having microscale patterns
that you're trying to emboss,
the computational burden
of using these full nonlinear,
finite, deformation polymer
models becomes immense.
And that's great if you have
one particular device that
absolutely must be perfect.
However, what we're interested
in doing in our research
is finding some sort
of middle ground
between the empirical
approach and the really
rigorous, thorough,
theoretical approach
that's based on a highly
controlled set of experiments.
And so the idea is to find
approximate descriptions
for the material that
are efficient to run,
efficient to simulate patterns,
wafers that have thousands
of features across them.
So let's start to think
about how we can build out
the bare bones of a
model that are going
to inform the experiments that
we do about this embossing
process.
Now, what I've done here-- and
I won't go into laborious detail
about, but essentially, this
is just building intuition
about one particular polymer.
This is a model for
polymethylmethacrylate,
plexiglass, acrylic,
call it what
you will, which a student
at MIT has recently
written a thesis about, doing
compression experiments of it,
building up a highly
faithful model of it.
But there's a one dimensional
implementation of that model
that we can run.
We can look at what happens
when you give it various load
profiles over time and look at
the stresses and the strains
in each of those components
of the model over time.
So what I've done
here is I've just
done two what are essentially
thought experiments.
The left hand column
of graphs shows
what happens if the material
is heated above its glass
transition temperature
and then given
a 1 and 1/2 megapascal
compressive load which
is held for 10 seconds.
That load is maintained while
the temperature is reduced
below the glass transmission.
The glass transition here
is about 105 degrees C.
So then we looked at how
the model responded to that.
There's a compressive
strain, of course.
There are stresses built
up in the left hand
branch of that model, this
spring and this dashpot.
And there are stresses in
the right hand side as well.
And essentially what this shows
is that most of the deformation
is frozen in place,
frozen by this
cooling below glass transition.
So when the load is removed,
this amount of strain
remains, this P amount here.
However, if you don't cool down
before you remove the load,
and that's what is
shown on the right,
then we see this recovery.
We see the material
springing back,
almost to its original shape.
And so there's a very small
residual compressive strain
in that case.
And just looking at a
distance, from a distance
at this simulation,
which is done
at a particular temperature,
140 degrees C, essentially
the material is behaving in a
springlike way predominantly.
Most of the deformation
is recovered
without cooling it to freeze
that deformation in place.
And you could run similar
thought experiments
at different temperatures,
different strain
rates with the model and get an
impression of how much of that
deformation is recovered
when the temperature is
kept at its elevated level
when you remove the load.
And so loosely speaking,
if most of the deformation
is recovered at
high temperature,
we would describe the material
as being rubbery over here.
This is a plot
essentially of the ratio
of that strain to
that strain, P over Q,
as a function of temperature
and peak compressive stress.
If that ratio is large,
we call it rubbery.
If the ratio is
small, in other words,
if there's been a lot
of plastic deformation
that doesn't spring
back upon unloading,
then we would sort of
classify the material
as being in a glassy state.
And sometimes glassy
is useful to you.
Sometimes rubbery is preferable.
So in any case, this sort
of intuition building
is helpful to us
in that it begins
to give us a starting point
for a physical model that
will let us choose what
experiments we're going to do,
and will let us build quick,
efficient simulations.
And so for that particular
temperature that I looked at
in detail, if you wanted
the simplest possible model
of the polymer, you
might just think
of making the model a
linear, elastic model, where
the Young's modulus was a
function of temperature.
And there are many
shortcomings of that.
If you hold the load
for long enough,
then there will of course be
plastic flow that's permanent.
And the material is
not linear elastic.
It changes its stiffness
as the strain increases.
But we might as well start
simple and see if it works.
It gives us information
about what types of features
replicate and what do not.
So that's what we
initially started with.
And the idea is that
increasing the temperature
reduces that modulus by three
or four orders of magnitude.
We form the shape,
and then we cool down
to freeze that
topography in place.
And what this is
going to let us do
is predict, for an
arbitrary stamp design,
what the shape of the
embossed part will be,
what its surface topography
will be for a chosen temperature
and pressure for embossing.
And here's the computational
approach that we decided upon.
And this is really quick to run.
The idea is that
we want to describe
how the surface of the material
responds to a point load.
And if the material
were linear elastic,
and if it were
substantially thicker
than the dimensions of
the features of interest,
then the topography in
response to a point load
would effectively go as one
over the radial distance
from the point where
the load is applied.
And that's a standard
contact mechanics result.
But we're talking
about computing
approximate topographies.
And this is going to be done
in a discretized way, where
we split the surface
of the polymer
into a series of square elements
so we can translate this point
load response into the
response of the surface
to unit pressure,
applied over one element
of our discretized surface.
So this is the plane of
the surface of the wafer,
the surface of the polymer.
And we are trying to express
how far that part of the surface
goes down when you apply
unit pressure here.
And that's the answer.
So we tried this with some
very simple geometries,
lots of parallel channels that
we had etched into silicon.
They were about 20 microns
deep, these silicon channels,
and on the order of
120 microns in pitch.
There are many channels
going across the screen.
But what we show
here is on the left,
scanning electron
micrographs of cross sections
through those embossed
structures, where
a variety of different
loads have been applied.
And the loads were held
for less than a minute.
So it's our working
assumption here
that all the
deformation was to do
with the rubbery
behavior of the material,
and there wasn't really enough
time for plastic flow to occur.
So we're just using our
zero [INAUDIBLE] model
to figure out what the Young's
modulus of the material
was essentially.
There's one parameter that we
fit in doing this simulation.
And that is the Young's modulus.
Here are simulations
done using that model.
So we're roughly
capturing the shape.
And it seems to
all stack up if we
choose this Young's modulus, 5
mega pascals at 130 degrees C.
So that's all very well.
But having these
parallel channels
doesn't give us too
much information
for a given experiment.
So we have to think
quite carefully
about what type of
characterization patterns
to use in these experiments.
We're trying to think
of ways of doing
a minimal number
of experiments that
will give us as much physical
information as possible.
And what we came
up with was this.
Here is a plan of the surface of
a silicon stamp that we etched.
And it's a square array of
various patches of features.
Some of them are
parallel channels.
Some of them are square holes.
And we have parallel channels
running in both directions.
So for every line to
space ratio of channels,
there's one set running
horizontally somewhere,
one set running vertically.
And they were arranged in a
random order across the stamp.
Now, there's one
twist to this, which
is that because we do
our simulation using
a discrete Fourier transform,
a fast Fourier transform,
the representation of the
space that we're simulating
is assumed to be
periodic in space.
So we accommodate that by
actually making the pattern
periodic.
What I show here is one
replicate of the pattern.
And this is about 4
millimeters in diameter.
But, in fact, what
we do is we have--
I suppose on the stamp
we have a 3x3 array where
what I've shown on the screen
is contained in this region.
So it's pseudo periodic
from the point of view
of the material surrounding it.
The material's a
millimeter thick.
This is 4 millimeters.
And so what's going
on at the edge here
looks exactly the
same to the material
as this material sees over here.
And that makes the simulation
match up with the experiments
nicely.
So we etch this stamp.
We choose some
embossing conditions,
press it into the
substrate, and use
white light scanning
interferometry
to measure the
surface topography.
The smallest features
in this particular stamp
are 5 micron in diameter.
What we're also
doing now actually
is a set of experiments where
we've scaled down this pattern
100-fold to make a nano
imprint lithography
stamp of the same pattern.
And so we're trying to tie all
the mechanics together and see
if similar effects
occur at the nanoscale.
Anyhow, in the bottom left
here is a composite map
of the surface, where the red
colors show that the higher
topography is where more
material has penetrated further
into the stamp cavities.
And on the right here
are eight cross-sections
through that topography,
labeled one, two, eight.
Experimental data is shown
in black, underneath.
And the prediction of
the linear elastic model,
with only one fitted
parameter, the Young's modulus,
is shown in red.
And you can see that there's
remarkable correspondence
between the two.
We get both a prediction of
how far on average material
penetrates cavities
of a given diameter.
And also, we do capture these
interactions of patterns
of different densities.
You can see, for
example, let's say--
well, I guess this
is a good example.
Here you're seeing many
instances of a given trench
diameter, but trenches that are
closer to different patterns
feel less far than those that
are in the center of the patch.
And this is all
captured reasonably
well by this rubbery
model of the polymer.
So looks like we've
got the basis here
for doing efficient simulations.
You can run that simulation
in 20 seconds in Matlab,
and it's giving you,
I think, probably
95% of the information a full
finite element simulation
would give you, as far as
topography is concerned.
So we can also abstract
our experimental results
and view them in simpler ways.
And one way of doing
that is to look
within each region of
features and measure
the peak penetration of
material into the cavity.
So we just measure
the range of heights
within the central 80% of the
area of each patch of features.
And then plot that
peak penetration
against some parameter.
In this case, I plotted
the pattern density,
which is the ratio of the cavity
width to the cavity pitch.
And the different
colors in this graph
represent different
feature pitches.
So the pitch being the distance
from one cavity to the next.
And what I show is the elastic
model matching up pretty well
with the experimental results.
Of course, you might
think that this
is leading towards the
possibility of non dimensional
groups to describe
features and how they fill,
and putting down design
rules that would tell you
how to scale the
embossing pressure
as your pattern's scaled down,
and these sorts of things.
So this is a great way
of viewing the results
and getting
intuition about them.
Of course, as you increase the
pressure and material starts
to touch the tops of
the stamp cavities,
this straight line
breaks down, of course.
And the red symbols
show what happens
when the pressure is increased
to a stage where the larger
cavities fill.
What you can also do is use
a series of these experiments
to get material properties
as a function of temperature
or of some other parameter.
And that's exactly
what we did here,
by doing a series
of embossing tests
at different temperatures.
And the gradient of that
line penetration to pressure
will be inversely proportional
to the effective elastic
modulus of the material.
So we did that.
We got out these values
for the Young's modulus
against temperature.
And luckily, they
match up really
nicely with a model
for Young's modulus
that was derived from bulk
compression experiments, that
was just done in a
big and strong load
frame using bulk materials.
So you could start to see how,
with careful choice of test
embossing patterns, we can
get a lot of information out
of a new material quite
quickly, scale information,
strain rate information perhaps,
temperature information.
And really, one of the
big challenges here
is deciding what are the
embossing tests you're
going to do, what combination
of temperatures and pressures
are you going to go for first
that will give you the most
information?
Now, I said before that
this rubbery model is really
only useful if the whole
time is comparatively short.
And often that's the case.
You want the cycle time to
be as short as possible.
So if you can get the
material into a state
where you press
hard enough, you get
the deformation almost
instantaneously,
then that's great.
But in a lot of cases,
you can't do that,
and you do get
this plastic flow.
So what I show here
is the evolution
of an embossed
topography over time
as we hold the load
at high temperature.
The black symbols
down here show what
happens if you start
cooling the material
down as soon as the
load reaches its peak.
So the material is
bowing into the cavities,
but hasn't gone very far.
And then right up here,
you've waited for 10 minutes.
And all but the
smallest features
have at least touched
the tops of the cavities.
Of course, this y-axis is
showing the peak penetration.
So it's the distance
from the top
of the feature to the bottom.
And it tells you nothing
about whether the corners
of the features
have been filled.
But this is a reasonably
useful measurement.
Now, the question is, can
we adapt our simple model
to capture this
viscoelastic behavior
without increasing the
computational burden very much?
And well, the next thing
you might think of doing
is adding a linear
dashpot into the system.
And maybe it's linear.
That would be the
first thing to try.
Maybe you do need to capture the
idea of a yield stress as well.
And maybe you need to capture
the idea of a strain rate
dependence, which
in PMMA is such
that the yield stress
increases substantially
with strain rates above about
10 to the minus 2 per second.
So, in fact, we just tried
adding in a linear dashpot.
So what this does, in effect,
is takes the point load
response associated
with purely rubbery,
purely linear elastic behavior,
which would be like this,
and scales it by a factor
that's related to the time
the load is applied.
And all that's saying is
imagine this was viscoelastic.
You applied a point load you get
some instantaneous deformation.
But over time, I'm saying this
surface is just scaling down.
All the points are staying
in the same ratio of height,
but it's just scaling down.
And we assume that
that scale factor
was proportional
to the hold time,
but you might not assume that.
You might say, well,
what if there's actually
a sort of limiting strain
where the polymer network is
as stretched out as it is it
can be for a particular load?
And in that case, you would
have I guess strain against time
would asymptotically approach
some limiting value that
was related to that spring.
And that would also be
quite easy to compute.
You compute a topography at
the start of the whole thing,
a topography that would be
associated with infinite time,
and then maybe interpolate
using an exponential function
of hold time.
But anyway, we just went
with a linear scaling.
And it seems to work
remarkably well.
For these particular
conditions, 110 degrees C,
which is a few degrees
above glass transition.
So we're definitely in a
region where plastic flow
is significant, is important.
And what we see, these are
the top experimental data,
3D plot of the
measurements taken
using optical interferometry
on the left for less than a
minute holding time,
loading duration,
and on the right when we left
that load in place for 10
minutes.
So you can see that obviously
over time the narrower features
start to fill.
And the simulation, to
a reasonable extent,
has captured that.
And in fact, the shortcoming
of the simulation
is that it underestimates
how quickly the narrower
features fill for the
parameters that we fit.
And so that is definitely
an imperfect model,
but it's pretty useful,
I think, for getting
a first cut of a simulation.
So, of course, now that we've
got this characterization idea,
we can apply that to
different materials.
And we did it with this
cyclic olefin polymer, ZEONOR,
which is a thermoplastic.
This one softens
around 135 degrees
C. It has quite a few
advantages over PMMA.
Although, it's
more expensive, it
doesn't absorb water
as readily, which
is pretty relevant to
microfluidic devices.
It transmits light to shorter
wavelengths, which is relevant
when you're exciting
fluorescent tags
inside the chip with UV light.
And so it's useful to
be able to characterize
these new materials
as they come along,
and when you don't necessarily
have an unlimited supply
of the material.
So again, this is a
plot of peak penetration
against cavity diameter.
And although most
of the data sit
on a roughly straight
line, when you have cavity
diameter being a large
proportion of the pitch,
in other words, there
are very narrow--
hello.
There are very narrow walls
of the stamp material pressing
into the polymer, that's
when the penetration does
seem to deviate from
this straight line.
So anyway, now, I've shown
you results from a few
carefully chosen
operating points.
And I showed a set
of results where
only temperature was varied.
And I showed some
for ZEONOR that
was only one temperature,
one hold time, one load.
And we need to start thinking
about what combination
of operating parameters
would we want
to deploy if we knew
nothing about a material
except for its approximate
glass transition temperature?
What would we want
to vary first?
And so you might
think about doing
some sort of fractional
factorial experiments
where your variables of
interest were those connected
with the process, the
temperature, the load, the hold
time, the time over which
the load is applied.
And that, indeed, is what I
did with a third material,
another brand of cyclic
olefin polymer called TOPAS.
And this is a material that
softens around 85 degrees C.
And so we did a 2 to the 4
minus 1 fractional factorial
where the four parameters
were embossing temperature,
peak embossing force,
hold time, and the time
over which the load was
ramped up to its peak.
And the astute among you will
notice that these variables are
not going to be independent,
because the average load
over the loading time will
contribute to the hold time.
So it's a rough and
ready set of experiments.
But nevertheless, it gives you
some idea of what we might do.
And here we have, again,
cavity penetration results
as a function of cavity width
for different feature pitches.
The top plot is for features
of a pitch of 100 microns.
And this is for 50 and 25.
And you see that, again, we
have this nice trend where
the peak penetration increases
up to a maximum value.
That maximum value is the height
of the cavities in the stamp.
And you'll also notice that
I've put these little black dots
on the graph as well.
And those are the measured
heights of the stamp cavities.
So you can see that actually the
heights of the stamp cavities
fall off for the
narrower cavities.
And that's associated with the
etching process that's used.
The actual plasma
etch that makes
the trenches in
the silicon stamp
has a harder time etching
the narrower trenches.
But it's a good sanity
check that we're actually
measuring the penetration of
polymer into the cavities.
Now, here are some
3D plots of results.
This in the top left, this
is essentially our standard,
our center point run
set of parameters
where for a 4
minute hold time you
get a reasonably good filling
of most of the feature sizes,
but it's not perfect.
So we can get an idea
of process variability.
This is a set of
parameters that was really
no use at all, 100 newtons.
We haven't even leveled out the
non-parallelism in the machine.
And one side of the substrate
was contacted with the stamp,
and the other was not.
So there's a lot of
missing data here.
And at 100 C, 900
Newtons, 8 minutes,
we pretty much got
complete filling
of most of the features.
So what we also
did, I should have
mentioned it randomized
the order of the samples
and interspersed these
center point runs.
Mohammed.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] with
feature sizes [INAUDIBLE]
small, that forces
[INAUDIBLE] [? 100 ?] Newtons,
does it damage the stamp?
PROFESSOR: In these experiments
we haven't damaged the stamp.
Actually, the
compressive stresses
experienced by the silicon
are nowhere near enough.
I mean, to break the
tensile strength of silicon
is over 100 mega pascals.
But actually where
the danger arises when
you're cooling the substrate.
And we'll get onto that.
But it's really
the lateral forces
applied to the protruding stamp
features that are dangerous,
because they create
moments on the features,
and can cause cracks at
the base of the feature
as it propagates.
So good question.
All right, so anyway,
interspersed center point runs.
And then what we've done
to provide some basis
for a test of significance
of the effects
is to take the average of
these peak penetrations.
So we've just taken the
mean over all feature
sizes, and orientations,
and everything,
and put it down here.
And so you can do an ANOVA.
And you can look
at the significance
of various effects.
And actually we get
the impression--
I mean, certainly temperature,
force, and hold time
is significant.
That is exactly
what we expected.
The question down here is, well,
at the 5% level, loading rate,
the time over which
that load is ramped up
is not appearing quite
to be significant.
But you know, we
don't know, because we
didn't make a very
judicious choice of aliasing
arrangements.
We don't know whether that's
really at the 7% level
significant that loading
time is a relevant factor,
or whether it's the interaction
of temperature, force, and hold
time.
Just thinking about
this intuitively,
you do expect the
interactions to be important.
You expect the product
of temperature and force
to be relevant, or some
non-linear combination
of the two parameters,
just because a temperature
imparts a strain rate
for a given force.
So increasing the force will
increase the strain rate
and so forth.
So anyway.
And also, as we probably
would have expected,
there's significant
curvature in the results.
And harking back to that graph
of modulus against temperature,
that's exactly what
we would expect.
Actually, I should have
highlighted when I showed you
this graph that there are trade
offs to be made in picking
these operating parameters.
On the one hand, you
might say I don't
want to heat the material
any hotter than is necessary.
I'd rather just press
as hard as I need to,
and maybe operate
at 120, 115 degrees
C where I can
deform the material.
And then because I'm not at
a very high temperature, when
I cool down, there isn't
going to be very much
differential thermal contraction
of the stamp on the substrate.
So I won't have big
residual stresses,
and I won't risk
breaking the stamp.
Now, that would be a really
logical thing to say.
And from a process
control perspective,
however, you can see that this
may not be a very good place
to operate, where
modulus is highly
sensitive to temperature.
And our personal experience
with lab apparatus-- and this
is probably different
in industry.
But controlling the temperature
is fairly difficult.
I mean, this is quite
an optimistic error bar,
in fact, to put on
the temperature.
So that's, I think, a really
relevant consideration
for choosing hot embossing
parameters, how sensitive we
are to temperature.
AUDIENCE: [? Given ?]
the temperature readouts,
plus minus 1 degree?
PROFESSOR: That's
what I estimated
for that particular
machine, yeah.
And I think that there
are also big challenges
to do with temperature
uniformity across [INAUDIBLE]..
Yeah, that's really something
that people are looking at.
So, in fact, the side of the
industry that's more advanced
is really the nano
imprint lithography side,
more so than the
micro embossing side.
And in that case, it's
more attractive to go
to very high temperatures, to
make the material behave more
like a viscous fluid than
like a rubbery material
or a viscoelastic.
So then temperature variation
isn't so much of an issue.
So you're right down in
the 4 megapascal range.
So but yes, good
point, absolutely.
Now, yes, there's one
really interesting thing
about these results.
And I mentioned that I had
two sets of each feature size.
And one was oriented vertically
on the stamp, and one
horizontally.
And I just put those on
there on the off chance
that there was anisotropy
in the materials.
And it turns out, with
this TOPAS sample, which
is a gift from the
supplier, there
is really strong anisotropy.
And so you can see that
the filled in symbols
are for an arbitrarily defined
orientation, 90 degrees,
and the open symbols
for 0 degrees.
So turning the feature
through 90 degrees
gives you this really big
difference in penetration.
And these results are
based on five replicates.
You can see the error bars
there at one standard deviation
of the five replicate results.
And there's definitely a
significant anisotropy.
Whether that's to do with
residual stress in the cast
sheet, alignment of
the polymer chains
because of some feature
of its processing, I mean,
you can start to see that
if materials like this
have such a big
orientation dependence,
and that is so dependent on
how they've been processed,
you can't necessarily know
the whole processing history
of what you're supplied.
It will be useful to
have these quick checks
of the properties of materials
that are given to you.
And you wouldn't be able to
get that information just
by a bulk compression
experiment.
So these carefully designed test
patterns are really important.
I should say that this is
anisotropy in the material,
not in the stamp.
Because if we rotate the
stamp relative to the sample,
the results reverse.
So it's definitely
in the material.
Anyhow, that was for TOPAS.
And I showed you a
few slides ago what
happens when hold
time is relevant,
when you've got plastic flow.
And we saw that the introduction
of this linear dashpot,
the scaling of the point
load response function
was a reasonably good
way of capturing that.
What we're working on
now is this ability
to capture yield
stress to iron out
some of the shortcomings
of the model, the fact
that those narrower features
actually filled more
than the model predicted.
And the other thing
that we're trying to do
is extend this simulation
approach to thin substrates
for the nano imprint
lithography case,
where this type of point
load response function
isn't correct.
The features are the
same size roughly
as the thickness
of the substrate.
You have to start thinking about
lateral transported material.
And that's quite
an exciting topic.
Now, we had a couple of
good questions about damage
to the stamp and
de-molding issues.
And this is perhaps
the biggest impediment
to the use of imprinting,
a microscale structure.
There's not that much of a
problem for nano imprint.
But microscale
structures, it's crucial.
And here are some examples of
problems that have occurred
during cooling and de-molding.
This is an SEM picture
of a PMMA component
that has been embossed
with a hexagonal post.
This was made from
silicon, in fact.
And if you imagine
the substrate being
mostly on this side of the
feature, cooled under load,
the polymer having at least
10 times the thermal expansion
coefficient as silicon,
it has pushed itself
against the sides
of the features.
And when we de-mold, we get
these really substantial
ridges.
I think this was embossed
at 130 degree C, 20 degrees
above the glass transition.
And so what we
haven't yet worked out
is whether these
contact stresses
are large enough
actually to push
the stamp off the substrate,
or whether it's just
elastic potential energy
stored in the polymer
that causes this ridge to
spring up when you peel
the stamp off the substrate.
Here are some
optical micrographs
showing a similar
problem, a triangular hole
embossed into a
polymer substrate.
The material is
contracted from right
to left relative to
the stamp feature.
And in fact, sometimes
we see these shards
of polymer being sheared
off, and again, a hole where
there's been a few tens of
microns relative contraction.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious, is there
any sort of like lubricant
that you can use to
increase the load?
PROFESSOR: There
are products you
can get that you can
spray onto the mold,
or, indeed, treatments that
can be given to the mold
to reduce the
coefficient of friction
between the mold
and the substrate.
That won't reduce the
magnitude of the lateral force.
That's to do with Young's
modulus and the coefficient
of thermal expansion.
But yes, it will
potentially make it easier
once that lateral force is
exerted to pull the stamp out.
However, it's not-- the problem
isn't all to do with friction.
Sometimes you have-- either
your stamp is imperfectly made,
and there's a negative draft.
I mean, I exaggerate, but if
that were the stamp and that
were the polymer,
that's a problem
that people run
into quite a lot.
And then if the
stamp has been made
by deep, reactive
ion etching where
there's this cyclic
etching process,
and there are these little,
sub micron scallops,
you're susceptible to
mechanical locking.
And there's plastic
deformation of the polymer
as you pull it off.
So it's a good point.
Yes, and actually, one thing
that does work quite well
is to leave the Teflon
polymeric coating on the silicon
after etching.
And that does do quite a lot.
It has a very limited
lifetime, though.
Anyway, the point
of saying all this
is, as I alluded to
a few minutes ago,
you might think of
reducing the temperature
swing to a small
a value as you can
so that amount of thermal
contraction is restricted.
You might even think of
removing the load slightly
above the glass
transition temperature.
And if you're in a
region where some
of the deformation, or
most of the deformation
is actually plastic,
which is true in a region
about 10 degrees above
glass transition for PMMA--
if you can exploit the
material properties to avoid
having a big temperature
swing, then that
could potentially
be very exciting.
And together with
Matt Dirks, who's
in the lab for manufacturing
and productivity,
we looked into this a
couple of years ago,
and found that if we control the
temperature really carefully,
then it was promising.
If you de-mold at 50 degrees C,
so well below glass transition,
and then pull the stamp off--
this is a cross-section through
the part--
then you get this
horrendous ridge
on the side of the
part nearer the edge,
the side of the feature
nearer the edge of the part.
If you de-mold, say, well
above glass transition, 120,
you get this blue line.
So you get some bowing of
the base of the feature where
material has sprung back.
And you get splaying
of the sidewalls.
And this was repeatable
over many samples.
However, if we can hit
110 degrees C on the nose,
we get a nice, flat feature.
We get nice, flat sidewalls.
And we get no ridge at all.
And that would be great.
But again, that's the thing.
Can you, in a
production setting,
make it 110, and not 115 or 120?
And that, I think, is
probably possible to achieve,
but would increase the
cost of the apparatus.
So this is definitely
something to be aware of.
Another thing that
is of importance
is that the risk
of the whole part
bowing if the de-molding
temperature is too high.
We've observed
problems with that.
So that needs to be
thought of as well.
Here we can see
also that if you're
going to remove the load at
or above the glass transition
temperature, you have
to pull out the stamp,
cool it down jolly quickly.
Because otherwise the part
will start to contract back
to its original flat surface.
And so you leave
it for 10 minutes,
things start to
look pretty poor.
OK, that is an overview of
about half of my thesis.
And since we're at half past
9:00, I think we should stop.
But are there any
questions from anyone?
If not, then I guess the
floor is open for questions
about the projects.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
mention one thing [INAUDIBLE]..
I think later today, hopefully,
or by tomorrow at the latest,
I'll post the tentative
schedule for what
groups will be presenting on
each of Tuesday and Thursday.
It will be in the
normal class period.
So we'll plan for that.
And I'll have some
other instructions,
like it'll be best, if possible,
to send those presentations
to me a little bit early.
I see we do have a USB port.
So it's possible we can add up
the presentations on the fly.
I don't know quite how well
that works out in Singapore.
We'll have to figure
that out as well.
But be alert.
Some of you, based
on random draw,
will be doing
presentations on Tuesday.
And some groups will be
doing that on Thursday.
Are there questions?
AUDIENCE: Is there
a rough guideline
for how long the IEEE
letter should be?
PROFESSOR: Oh, the IEEE paper?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I think typically--
whatever it takes to
do a reasonable job.
I think something
typically on the order
of six, seven, eight
pages is, I think,
what we often saw in the past.
Sometimes it might be
a little bit shorter,
depending on how much
background you have.
So I don't have a
strict page guideline.
Good.
Any questions in
Singapore on that?
OK, great.
AUDIENCE: Professor.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: We have a
question for our project.
We actually have two questions.
So one question is that we
have two outputs in our--
can you hear me?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
speak up a little bit.
AUDIENCE: OK, so one question
is that we have two outputs,
and then we are
measuring the data.
But these two outputs, they
are negatively correlated.
And our objective is
to maximize one output
and minimize the other output.
So we understand that
we can do it separately
in our optimization.
But when we want
to sort of create
a combined an objective
function and optimize these two
together, as they come from
the same set of inputs, how can
we do that?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so the
classic approach there
is it's a trade off.
Right?
One or the other.
And what you typically
do is apply a weight
to the two alternatives.
So you have a different
numeric weight
based on your engineering
importance, or the customer
importance, or whatever
of the two effects.
So you have one function
that combines, say,
squared deviations
in the two outputs,
but with a different
weight on the two outputs.
AUDIENCE: OK, I see.
PROFESSOR: OK?
You're all set?
AUDIENCE: We have another
question actually.
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: I have
one more question.
It's regarding the
email you sent us.
So we were told that we can
explore one factor [INAUDIBLE]
strategy.
We are not quite sure what
strategy you are referring to.
Is it studying the output
and one input at a time?
Or is it more like
stepwise regression?
PROFESSOR: No, I'm referring
to the optimization approach,
the One Factor At a Time, OFAT,
that Professor Dan [? Frey ?]
talked about in his lecture.
So where you
explore the corners.
You look and see if
you've improved it or not,
to decide if you keep that move.
And then once you
do make a move,
then you randomly
decide which next corner
to experimentally try.
So you've actually got the
data already done from a DOE.
But now you can pretend
you were actually
running the experiment just one
experimental point at a time
using the OFAT approach.
And I think that
would be interesting
for online optimization to
compare also to response
surface modeling optimization.
AUDIENCE: OK.
All right, thanks.
PROFESSOR: Great, all right.
See you guys later.